ASSISTS.
A NICE BOUNCEBACK GAME.
AND HOW WILL THE SUNS RESPOND ON
WEDNESDAY NIGHT?
CAN'T WAIT TO FIND OUT.
RIGHT NOW, LET'S CHECK IN WITH
MALIKA.
>> Malika: GIANNIS, BACK-TO-BACK
40-POINT GAMES FOR YOU.
WHAT TYPE OF MENTAL FOCUS DID
YOU BRING TONIGHT?
>> WE KNEW WHAT TYPE OF GAME IT
WOULD BE, WE KNEW WE WOULD HAVE
TO COME HERE, PLAY GOOD
BASKETBALL, COMPETE AS HARD AS
POSSIBLE.
I JUST WANTED TO BE AGGRESSIVE,
MAKE THE RIGHT PLAY, AND TAKE IT
A POSSESSION AT A TIME.
>> Malika: FROM THE OPENING TIP,
YOU WERE TRYING TO GET YOUR
TEAMMATES INVOLVED.
WHY WAS THAT A POINT OF
EMPHASIS?
>> I WANTED TO GET DOWNHILL,
OPEN UP DRIVING LANES.
I WANTED TO GET ALL OF THEM
INVOLVED.
IF I HAD PATIENCE, I WAS ABLE TO
BREAK THE DEFENSE.
BY THE END OF THE DAY, MY
MENTAL, WHAT I THINK IS ALWAYS
STAY AGGRESSIVE, GET DOWNHILL.
AFTER THAT, JUST TRY TO MAKE THE
RIGHT PLAY OR PASS.
>> Malika: YOU SHOT INCREDIBLY
WELL FROM THE FREE-THROW LINE
TONIGHT.
NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE COUNTING 1,
2, 3.
WHAT WAS WORKING FOR YOU?
>> JUST TRYING TO FOCUS ON
MYSELF.
FOCUS ON MY TECHNIQUE, MY BODY.
AND, YOU KNOW, ONCE YOU SEE A
FEW GOING IN, YOU GET A LITTLE
BIT MORE CONFIDENCE.
AND YOU MAKE A FEW MORE.
BUT MY TEAMMATES, JUST, THEY
KEEP ME ACCOUNTABLE, THEY WANT
ME TO BE AGGRESSIVE AND GET TO
THE FREE-THROW LINE AND KNOCK
SHOTS DOWN THERE.
THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO.
>> Malika: WHAT IS THE KEY TO
NOT LETTING GO OF THE ROPE IN
GAME FOUR?
>> WE KNOW WHAT TYPE OF GAME IT
WILL BE.
IT'S ALL MENTAL.
WE NEED TO GIVE OURSELVES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WIN THIS GAME AND
THIS SERIES.
TO BE